auch die linke hat übrigens heute
mehrere änderungsanträge noch vorgelegt
wir hören ist die fraktionsvorsitzende
am ihrer mohammed ali
es geht um leben und tod
das infektionsgeschehen das muss
dringend eingedämmt werden aber es macht
die bundesregierung
sie taumelt von einem murks in den
nächsten und auch jetzt legen sie uns
wieder ein stück werk vor was die großen
probleme nicht lösen wird und das ist
unverantwortlich in verdreckten woche
haben sie im bevölkerungsschutz gesetz
einiges ungeschickt die maßnahmen sind
es befristet der persilschein für die
bundesregierung weitere maßnahmen zu
erlassen ist entfallen gut aber die
wahrheit ist dass sie sich hier erst
auch unseren massiven druck hin bewegt
haben und das erleben wir übrigens nicht
zum ersten mal in dieser pandemie dass
sie versuchen grundrechts
einschränkungen einschränkungen
praktisch im vorbeigehen ohne befristung
einzuführen und die befugnisse der
regierung massiv auszuweiten
das ist und bleibt untragbar ich kann
ihnen versichern
die linke wird das niemals akzeptieren
wir
wir leben ihr gesetz weiterhin ab und
ich sage ihnen auch warum sie wollen
ausgangssperren pauschalen sident von
100 verhängen obwohl die wirksamkeit
dieser maßnahme hoch umstritten ist aber
der eingriff in die grundrechte massiv
was jedoch wissenschaftlich sehr gut
belegt ist
das ist der hohe anteil an ansteckungen
am arbeitsplatz trotzdem nehmen sie nach
wie vor die arbeitgeber nicht richtig in
die pflicht unglaublich ja worauf es
vollkommen aber sie kontrollieren es
nicht richtig ja test sollen kommen aber
nicht verpflichtend nur ein angebot für
ein bis zwei tests pro woche
das ist doch zahnlos also die zeit dass
man immer noch bitte bitte unternehmen
sagt die muss doch endlich vorbei sein
wir brauchen endlich schutz für alle
menschen an allen arbeitsplätzen und
auch auf dem weg zur arbeit in den
schulen
schon lange schlagen schülervertreter
eltern lehrer alarm und was tun siegen
obwohl sie auf einer inzidenz von 100
ausgangssperren verhängen wollen sollen
die kinder bis zu einer inzidenz von 165
in die schule gehen also ich kann alle
eltern verstehen die dann nur noch mit
dem kopf schütteln können woher haben
sie eigentlich diese zahlen und würfeln
wie die auf und es ist auch irrsinn dass
die kinder desto hunderte incident in
voller klassenstärke unterrichtet werden
sollen
die klassenstärken wir müssen reduziert
werden das ist der schlüssel
und genauso kann nur den kopf schütteln
über ihre pläne
dass kinder bis 14 jahren im freien
sport treiben dürfen ab 15 aber nicht
mehr
ich meine dass du auch so brauchen
kinder ab 15 weniger bewegung und
ausgleich ich mein flieger wieder denken
sie eben nicht an die jungen menschen
die eben keine großen gärten und
spielzimmer haben aber das ist leider
nichts neues
diese bundesregierung ignoriert
konsequent die tatsache dass die
gefahren von kogit 19 eben nicht für
alle menschen gleich sind
das ansteckungsrisiko und das risiko
eines schweren verlaufs ist für menschen
mit niedrigem einkommen
nachgewiesenermaßen deutlich höher
wegen der enge wohnverhältnisse weil man
nicht im home office arbeiten kann weil
man in vollen bussen und bahn zur arbeit
fahren muss um bahn zur arbeit fahren
muss und kommen auf eine schlechtere
gesundheitsversorgung haben und sich
gesunde ernährung nicht leisten können
das ist die wahrheit die verkäuferin
lieferant die erzieherin
es ist doch wirklich eine schande das
sieht die menschen die sie hier wieder
und wieder geklatscht und gelobt haben
weil sie die wahren stützen unserer
gesellschaft in dieser pandemie sind
dass sie die immer noch nicht genügend
schützen sondern weiterhin im stich
lasst unsere position als linke ist klar
wir brauchen infektionsschutz und er
muss solidarisch sein
niemand darf auf der strecke bleiben und
das heißt wirksamer schutz an allen
arbeitsplätzen und auf dem weg zur
arbeit viel mehr text und luftfilter für
die schulen bessere unterstützung von
lehrern und eltern auch im homescreen
und natürlich müssen endlich die
sozialen härten dieser pandemie
vernünftig abgefedert werde es geben
dass angst und verzweiflung bei immer
mehr menschen um sich greifen deshalb
drängen wir seit über einem jahr darauf
endlich ausreichende und unbürokratische
hilfen so scheint's unternehmen zur
verfügung zu stellen inklusive eines
unternehmens für solo selbständige
künstlerinnen und künstler wir brauchen
außerdem unbedingt eine verlängerung der
auszahlung von arbeitslosengeld 1 einen
monatlichen zuschlag für menschen in
grundsicherung und eine angemessene
gehaltserhöhung für alle pflegerinnen
und pfleger und alle anderen durch die
pandemie im gesundheitswesen im
einzelhandel und im grunde logistik
doppelt und dreifach belastet werden ja
und
ich werde nicht aufhören das hier zu
sagen wohnungs mit kündigungen und
stromsperren auf grund finanzieller nöte
die gehören verboten kolleginnen
kollegen aber ich befürchte kolleginnen
und kollegen von der bundesregierung all
das stößt bei ihnen wieder auf taube
ohren
und sie werden unsere anträge die wir
heute einbringen wieder nicht annehmen
dabei wäre das so dringend nötig denn es
ist vollkommen klar es ist so nicht
weitergehen kann weder in dieser
pandemie noch danach
wir brauchen ein gesundheitswesen in den
nicht der profit sondern das wohl der
patienten im mittelpunkt steht
wir brauchen schulen mit ausreichend
personal und mitteln um allen kindern
eine bessere bildung zu garantieren
wir brauchen einen sozialstaat der die
menschen zusammenführt und das land fit
für die zukunft macht aber sie können
sich darauf verlassen dass wir als linke
dafür weiter entschlossen kämpfen
[Applaus]